- By being a racing driver,
you are under risk all the time.
I use those lines and those guidelines
to move as a man, as a professional.
I like to do well, I like to be the best.
I am as, committed as ever to my passion.
Everyone is responsible for
the race having being started.
I am only 32 and it's
no sense for me to stop.
- [Announcer] (commentates in Portuguese)
(car engines roaring)
- He's a Brazilian race driver
who won three Formula
One world championships.
- He was killed in an accident
while leading the 1994
San Marino Grand Prix.
- He's considered by many as
the greatest race car driver of all time.
- He's Ayrton Senna,
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
(music)
- You should know that
by being a racing driver,
you are under risk all the time.
By being a racing driver means,
you are racing with other people.
And if you no longer go
for a gap that exists,
you no longer a racing driver,
because we are competing,
we are competing to win.
And the main motivation to all of us,
is to compete for victory.
It's not to come third,
fourth, fifth or sixth.
- [Interviewer] (speaks in Portuguese)
- [Ayrton] (speaks in Portuguese)
I have had all my life a very,
very strong and good education.
And from that education I've got, again,
clear and strong principals
in way of behaving.
And that's where I guide for...
I use those lines and those guidelines
to move as a man, as a professional.
And I don't regret anything,
I just feel I'm doing
things for the right reason.
Some understand, some don't.
In the end you never get
everybody to understand,
to agree and to accept.
But most of them, I'm sure,
admire after all, what I'm doing
as a professional and as a man
and as many drivers do.
We are exposing our lives,
they are consistent.
And the reason for it is only one,
it's to succeed, it's to win.
It's to get the thrill when
you cross the finish line
in first place.
I am very competitive.
I think any racing driver
that gets to Formula One,
has in expressionality,
a lot of competitiveness.
I particularly believe to
be extremely competitive
in anything I do.
But it depends where you
are and what you're doing
and what is your state of mind.
If I'm on holiday, off season,
it's a different way of living totally
then when you do interviews,
when you're testing,
you're in the season of racing,
competing during the season.
You have to allow yourself
different mental approach,
a different way of looking
the day and night.
And only that way I find possible
to get the necessary equilibrium
to then give everything I
have when it really matters.
But in normal things I am competitive.
I like to compete and I like to do well.
I like to be the best.
- [Ayrton] (speaks in Portuguese)
- Ayrton, it has been a quite
incredible season for you.
You are the youngest ever
three times world champion,
three times in four years.
I have to ask you on behalf
of your despairing rivals.
Is your motivation still as high as ever?
- I think so. (laughter)
I am as you said, young and healthy.
I am as committed as ever
to my passion, to our passion,
and to my profession.
And the main thing is to find the ways
time after time to stimulate myself
in my own world, my own funny ways.
To dedicate a lot of my time
and a lot of my thinking
and keep up when the commitment
is quite high to continue,
to be successful.
- (Reporter) If we were to
run into rain conditions
of this kind again, is
there a better method,
Ayrton, for us to look into how the race
should be stopped, earlier or more--
- We shouldn't start. (crosstalk)
I think it's very hard
for the officials to make
such a decision, because
there is a lot of pressure.
Television all over the world, and...
And it's difficult, we understand.
But I think it's, in a
way, it's our own fault.
We shouldn't have started as drivers,
if we just get out of
the cars, stick together,
and make a decision for ourselves,
then the race wouldn't
start in the first place.
It's always very difficult
to get everyone together,
I've experienced it myself
two years ago, today again,
because also we have a
lot of responsibility
to the teams and the sponsors
that give us so much,
and there are moments that we have to also
try to give them some simple--
it's very difficult to find equilibrium
to balance on making the right decisions
at every single time, but as I said,
I think it was a mistake to
all of us to have started.
Not only from the officials,
it was also driver's mistake,
was team's mistake, we all
should have courage as a group.
Everyone that is here to get
together and go against it,
and not start the race.
So it's not officials only,
I also take responsibility,
as drivers, and also the team--
everyone is responsible for
the race having been started.
I expressed the feeling some
time ago, a couple months ago
that I wouldn't be prepared
to continue driving next year,
unless I felt I could
compete--competitive,
and that meant not that I had
to leave McLaren or anything,
it just meant if you feel you have
some light at the end
of the tunnel in which
you can work and make up, and
be back in a compeititve way.
And if that situation, did not...
Turn up for me, then I wouldn't drive.
Without really wishing to stop,
because I am only 32, and it
is no sense for me to stop,
I mean, the peak of my career is
still with quite few years ahead.
I have achieved so much
credibility, so much experience,
that is it's not the time to
stop, but on the other hand,
there's absolutely no sense
to just be a number out there,
giving the fact that whether
you're fighting for first
or second, or fifth or sixth,
you just expose yourself
to a lot of danger
continuously, a lot of stress,
and a lifestyle that not
always is attractive for me.
Therefore, considering everything,
the material benefits I got up until now,
and the ones I could get in the future,
the personal satisfaction,
the achievements that you can get,
and the only real motivation
for me to continue
was to be in a position where
I could compete, improve,
learn more and be there.
Be there fighting at least for it.
And anything else, I could
not justify to myself.
(Ayrton speaking Portuguese)
(crowd cheering)
- [Reginaldo] (speaking Portuguese)
- [Announcer] (commentates in Portuguese)
- [Ron] Ayrton pulled out in the lead,
he was then really faced
with a very easy race win.
- [Announcer] (speaks Portuguese)
- [Ron] And then, the gearbox jammed,
and he was faced with several laps to go,
only having the sixth gear.
- [Reginaldo] (speaks in Portuguese)
- [Announcer] (commentates in Portuguese)
- [Ayrton] (screams)
(crowd cheering)
- [Reginaldo] (speaks Portuguese)
- [Ayrton] (speaks Portuguese)
- Thank you so much for watching,
we made this video because
Devesh Somani asked us to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want us to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and we'll see what we can do.
- We would love to know which
one of his top ten rules
that you like the most,
please leave a comment below
before joining the discussion.
- Thank you guys for
watching, continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- Bye!